[Music]
many people assume there are many
peaceful verses in the Quran and indeed
there are several peaceful verses in the
Quran one notable passage in joining
tolerance is s 109 which says in its
entirety say oh disbelievers I do not
worship what you worship nor do you
worship what I worship and I shall not
worship what you worship nor will you
worship what I worship to you is your
religion and to me is my religion other
verses add to this seeming indifference
the contention that Allah will
ultimately judge the unbelievers and
cast them into hell thus Allah tells
Muhammad not to waste his time arguing
with those who reject his message but to
leave them in peace until that terrible
day so the Quran says so leave them
alone until they encounter that day of
theirs on which they will swoon
above all no muslim should forcibly
convert an unbeliever and the famous
passage of the Quran says let there be
no compulsion in religion truth stands
out clear from error whoever rejects
evil and believes in Allah has grasped
the most trustworthy handhold that never
breaks and Allah hears and knows all
things following this celebrated verse
comes another threat of Hell Quran says
Allah is the protector of those who have
faith from the depths of Darkness he
will lead them forth into light of those
who reject Faith the patrons are the
evil ones from light they will lead them
forth into depths of Darkness they will
be Companions of the fire to dwell
therein since Jews and Christians called
the people of the book in the Quran will
face exactly that Dreadful judgment
Allah admonishes his Prophet not to
argue with them instead he is to
emphasize that he believes in the same
God they do and so the Quran sayso not
dispute with the people of the book
except with better means unless it be
with those of them who inflict wrong but
say we believe in the Revelation which
has come down to us and in that which is
come down to you our Allah and your
Allah is one and it is to him we bow and
then of course there's one of the most
often quoted verses of the Quran which
goes like this because of that we
decreed upon the children of Israel that
whoever kills a soul unless for a soul
or for corruption in the land it is as
if he had slain mankind entirely and
whoever saved one it is as if he had
saved mankind entirely and our
Messengers had certainly come to them
with clear proofs then indeed many of
them after that throughout the land were
transgressors now there's less to this
than Western leaders and Islamic
apologists claim first it's not a
general prohibition of killing there are
big exceptions For Those Who Kill for a
soul or for corruption in the land
second this is not a general command but
one only for the children of Israel
third many of them after that were
transgressors it says so all that it's
really saying is that Allah gave a
command to the children of Israel and
they transgressed against it nor do most
of the people who mention that verse
mention that it's followed by verse 533
which specifies the punishment for the
corruption and transgressions of the
children of Israel that verse goes like
this indeed the penalty for those who
wage war against Allah and his messenger
and strive upon the Earth corruption is
none that they be killed or crucified or
that their hands and feet be cut off
from opposite sides or that they be
exiled from the land that is for them a
disgrace in this world and for them in
the Hereafter a great punishment but
what about the other passages enjoining
tolerance and patience with unbelievers
many traditional Islamic theologians and
Quran commentators actually argue that
violent material such as the verse of
the sword which is the celebrated
command to slay the idolators wherever
you find them actually abrogates more
relatively tolerant material now this
means that whatever the Quran teaches
about peace with unbelievers is
superseded and overridden by passages
enjoining violence and that doctrine of
abreg is also based on the Quran itself
for more information about this go to
this website
[Music]